la séance est ouverte le contendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation
il y en a-t-il en séance je n'en vois
point le procèsverbal est adopté sous
les réserves d'usage notre ordre du jour
appelle la lecture d'une déclaration du
gouvernement je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
qui lira cette déclaration devant le
Sénat monsieur le
ministre
vous avez la parole merci à Monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs comme la tradition le veut
j'ai l'honneur de m'adresser devant vous
pour vous faire part de la déclaration
de politique générale du Premier
ministre qui lit en ce moment devant
l'Assemblée nationale le Pr ministre
s'adressera par ailleurs devant vous
demain à
15h le propre de toute société humaine
c'est de regarder en face l'avenir qui
se dessine devant elle interroger son
modèle puiser en soi les ressources
suffisantes pour avancer corriger ce qui
doit l'être construire les bonnes
solutions une société ne se perd jamais
quand elle cherche à avancer une société
ne se perd jamais quand elle doute elle
se perd quand le doute l'emporte sur
tout le reste quand le doute glace quand
il fige quand il conduit à douter non
pas de l'avenir qui se dessine mais à
douter de soi-même de ses forces et de
ses
capacités je suis né en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez-y monsieur le ministre moi non
mais
allez-y si
seulement l'année du bicentenaire de la
Révolution une année où on a cru que la
démocratie libérale et le progrès
universel triompherai par eux-même ma
génération a vu l'inverse se produire
parce que notre génération partout dans
le monde voit son monde bouler plus
fortement encore que tout autre avant
elle elle est en proie au doute doute
sur l'avenir de sa planète doute sur son
identité doute ici en France sur qui
nous sommes comme peuple et comme nation
doute sur notre modèle social nos
services publics notre
démocratie notre responsabilité celle de
chacune et de chacun d'entre nous c'est
de puiser en nous la force d'identifier
tous les ressorts pour les surpasser si
nous sommes là etci réuni si nous nous
engageons par-delà nos divergences et
nos désaccords c'est que nous avons un
point commun partagé par des dizaines de
millions de nos concitoyens nous voyons
davantage de raisons d'espérer que de
douter c'est parce que nous sommes prêts
à affronter pour avancer affronter pour
avancer en France mesdames et messieurs
les députés mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs en m'exprimant face à vous
c'est en réalité à chaque citoyen de
notre pays que je m'adresse et à travers
vous c'est à chacun de nos concitoyens
que je veux le dire nous ne sommes pas
n'importe quel pays la France n'a jamais
été n'est pas et ne sera jamais une
nation qui subit ni hier ni aujourd'hui
ni demain dans les pires moments de
doute de désarroi de désunion elle a
montré sa solidité son supplément d'âme
qui fait d'è une nation à nul autre
pareil en cette année 2024 N
commémoreront les 80 ans du débarquement
moment de libération d'une France de
soutien des Français qui pour la plupart
n'avaient jamais cessé de croire en elle
en cette année 2024 nous rouvrirons les
portes de Notre-Dame de Paris alors que
l'image des flammes reste si vive dans
l'esprit des Français en cette année
2024 nous accueillerons le monde un
monde bouleversé divisé oui nous
accueilleront le monde à l'occasion des
Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques la France rime avec
puissance
la France est un repère un idéal c'est
un patrimoine témoin d'une histoire
millénaire c'est un héritage moral celui
de la patrie où sont nés les droits de
l'homme c'est un modèle social
protecteur et envier dans le monde
entier la France est le pays de la
création que nous soutenons et qui nous
fait rayonner c'est la patrie de la
recherche à laquelle nous donnons des
moyens sans précédent c'est la nation de
l'innovation qui construit le monde de
demain de
2030 la France ce sont nos jeunes qui
osent et se lancent ce sont nos familles
et toutes ces mères célibataires qui se
battent qui ne lâche rien jamais ce sont
nos soignants nos professeurs nos forces
de l'ordre tous nos agents publics nos
militaires qui s'engagent pour quelque
chose qui les dépasse ce sont nos
artisans qui font rayonner nos
savoir-faire ce sont nos agriculteurs
nos pêcheurs qui travaillent matin midi
et soir pour nous nourrir ce sont nos
élus locaux qui s'engagent et se donnent
cor es pour leur territoire ce sont nos
associations nos bénévoles la France et
68 millions de Français de l'Hexagone
des outrem et de l'étranger qui n'ont
pas fini de nous surprendre dans un
monde où tout s'accélère et se
transforme je refuse avec eux que notre
identité puisse se diluer ou se
dissoudant la France a son rang à tenir
sa voix à faire entendre sa singularité
à imposer nous avons une fierté
française à maintenir une une fierté
européenne à consolider affronter pour
avancer les difficultés économiques les
bouleversements climatiques
démographique géopolitique ne nous
figeront jamais ne nous conduiront
jamais à nous perdre il ne signifie pas
la fin de tout mais le passage d'un
monde à un autre un passage difficile
douloureux inquiétant à bien des égards
mais un passage que nous réussirons j'en
suis intimement convaincu à ceux qui
veulent y voir notre disparition j'y
vois notre renaissance
parce que nous avons une identité et des
valeurs à ceux qui veulent y voir un
triangle des Bermudes j'y vois notre
caporne parce que nous savons où nous
voulons aller à ceux qui veulent y voir
une perte de boussole j'y vois une
détermination parce que j'ai
confiance confiance parce que je connais
le chemin que nous avons parcouru depuis
2017 les tabous que nous avons levés les
obstacles que nous avons franchi j'ai
confiance parce que je connais des
Français leur énergie leur volonté
leur
créativité j'ai confiance parce que je
sais que face aux épreuves aux
inquiétudes et aux crises notre pays
c'est toujours
relevé l'épidémie de covid a mis à jour
bon nombre de fractures notre société
elle a poussé notre modèle social dans
ses retranchements mais notre pays a
tenu et nous avons protégé nos
concitoyens mieux que beaucoup d'autres
l'ont fait le dérèglement climatique
nous frappe plus dur plus fort plus
souvent l'exceptionnel devient les
catastrophes se multiplient mais notre
pays agit avec force et jamais dans son
histoire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre n'ont baissé aussi rapidement que
l'an
dernier la guerre en Ukraine a ébranlé
l'Europe
elle a détruit le rêve d'une paix
éternelle sur notre continent elle nous
a rappelé durement que la démocratie
était fragile et la liberté un idéal
toujours à défendre mais notre pays
notre Europe ont montré le visage de la
détermination face à l'agresseur et de
la solidarité pour le peuple
ukrainien l'attaque terroriste
monstrueuse en Israël et la guerre au
proche- Orient ont ravivver des PLA et
des maots jusque dans notre société mais
notre pays a su se dresser répondre par
le refus de la haine et par l'unité la
crise énergétique l'inflation la menace
terroriste les crises se superposent
s'enchevêre s'additionnent elle n'offre
aucune solution miraculeuse mais
méthodiquement avec les Français nous y
bien sûr face à ces crises pour beaucoup
de Français l'avenir est davantage une
crainte qu'une promesse et encore trop
de Français ont le sentiment de perdre
le contrôle de leur propre vie avec le
président de la République avec mon
gouvernement je ne me résous pas je n'y
me résoudrai jamais pour tous ces
Français nous allons continuer à
affronter pour avancer pas par des
belles paroles des grandes tirades ou de
beaux discours mais par des actes et
concret de nouveaux changements dans
leur vie et sur le terrain monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs sous l'égide du président de
la République l'identité même de cette
majorité de ce gouvernement c'est de
reconquérir notre souveraineté française
et européenne notre promesse au français
est claire oui nous voulons reprendre
notre destin en main en ouvrant une
nouvelle page cette conquête nous
pouvons nous appuyer sur un bilan
concret solide
tangible en 2017 ma génération n'avait
connu que la désindustrialisation qui
semblait inéductable le chômage de masse
qui s'ancrait l'Europe qui se
désunissait la transition écologique qui
rimait avec nécessité plus qu'avec
réalité au fond en 2017 la souveraineté
de la France et de l'Europe était pour
beaucoup un impensé pour certains même
c'était un gros mot nous avons assumé de
parler de souveraineté et plus important
encore nous avons assumé d'en faire la
matrice de notre action et nous avons
agi nous avons engagé une action résolue
pour la souveraineté économique avec
pour la première fois le retour de
l'industrie sur notre sol dans déplais
au Cassandre il y a désormais plus
d'usines qui ouvrent que d'usin qui
ferment en France plus d'emplois
industriels qui sont créés que détruits
ça n'était pas arrivé depuis 30 ans
notre taux de chômage est descendu
jusqu'à un niveau jamais atteint depuis
25 ans et pour la 5e année consécutive
notre pays est le plus attractif d'eope
pour les investissements
étrangers nous avons engagé une action
résolue pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et conquérir
notre indépendance énergétique avec une
planification écologique inédite dans le
monde et une stratégie énergétique pour
une énergie plus souveraine et plus
durable nous avons engagé une action
résolue pour la souveraineté de nos
frontières avec une loi immigration et
impact asile immigration au niveau
européen enfin réellement protecteur
pour notre pays nous avons engagé une
action résolue pour que chaque française
et chaque Français puisse garder le
contrôle de sa propre vie qu'il ne soit
jamais entravé jamais assigné à
résidence jamais résigné et évidemment
nous avons engagé une action résolue
pour la souveraineté agricole de notre
pays mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
notre agriculture est notre force pas
simplement parce qu'elle nous alimente
au sens propre du terme mais parce
constiue l'un des fondements de notre
identité de nos traditions parce que nos
agriculteurs incarnent des valeurs
fondamentales et qui lurquelles sont
bridées fragilis l'ensemble de la
société la valeur du travail de l'effort
la liberté
d'entreprendre notre agriculture est
notre force et notre fierté aussi alors
je le dis ici
solonnellement il doit y avoir une
exception agricole française je suis
lucide face à l'empilement des normes
face aux décisions qui tombent d'en haut
et qui parfois tombent dans ne sait où
elle doute elle aussi et elle attend des
réponses et des solutions nous serons au
rendez-vous sans
ambigué monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs devant vous
je prends la parole humble face à
l'ampleur de la tâche à accomplir je
veux m'adresser à tous les Français ceux
qui doutent et ceux qui espèrent ceux
qui écoutent et ceux qui n'y croient
plus je veux m'adresser à tous ces
Français souvent dans la classe moyenne
toujours au rendez-vous de leur
responsabilité qui ne se plaignent pas
alors qu'ils ont si souvent le sentiment
de subir à ces Français qui ont le
sentiment d'avoir tous les devoirs quand
d'autres ont tous les droits ass ces
Français qui ont parfois le sentiment
que leur propre pays s'éloignent qui n'y
ont plus vraiment leur place alors
qu'ils en sont le cœur battant àees
français de l'Entre Deux trop riches
pour bénéficier des aides mais pas assez
pour ne pas compter qui ont le sentiment
que les décisions se prennent sans eux
et qu'elle bénéficie toujours au même à
ces Français qui ont parfois
l'impression de vivre dans une France
archipelle dont les ponts seraient sur
le point de se rompre mais ces Français
qui espèrent au fond d'eux qu'on
parviendra à les réunir à ces Français
qui ne demandent pas la lune mais
simplement à pouvoir vivre de leur
travail éduquer leurs enfants se soigner
et vivre en sécurité je les entends je
les comprends et comme la majorité y
uvre depuis 2017 je veux y répondre
je le veux avec d'autant plus de
détermination que je sais le risque pour
eux de les laisser céder à des sirènes
qui ne conduiraiit qu'au chaos à la
division et à l'affrontement car je suis
lucide pendant que nous agissons
certains guett entretiennent les colères
et espèrent en récolter des fruits
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
défi est immense et j'ai bien conscience
que nous ne pourrons pas le relever seul
avec mes ministres que je remercie pour
leur engagement sans faille j'ai bien
conscience aussi du message très clair
exprimé par les Français en
2022 nous avons une majorité que je
salue et à qui je veux dire ma confiance
et ma fidélité mais cette majorité est
relative et les Français attendent que
nous cessionions les querelles de
principes pour échanger et pour agir
ensemble depuis 18 mois sur bien des
textes nous y sommes parvenus et
aujourd'hui je le dis à la majorité
comme position nous avons la France en
partage nous avons je le crois un devoir
commun de transcender les clivage les
désaccords et les divisions pour rrer au
service des
Français évidemment nous ne serons pas
d'accord sur tout évidemment nous nous
opposerons dans cet hémicycle et
ailleurs mais je vous le dis je ne
renoncerai jamais à dialoguer ma porte
sera toujours ouverte parce qu'à travers
vous mesdames et messieurs les députés
des oppositions ce sont des les voies de
millions de Français qui s'exprime c'est
aussi cela la méthode que je veux pour
mon gouvernement respecter les Français
respecter les oppositions respecter
notre Parlement je m'y engage et j'en
serai le
garant ma méthode a toujours été la même
chaque Français porte une vérité sur
notre pays nous devons l'écouter et y
répondre forces politiqu organisation
syndical élus locaux français depuis ma
nomination j'ai entamé des change
toujours avec franchise et lucidité
alors avec vous je veux faire raisonner
les mots de nos concitoyens répondre à
leurs inquiétude et porter leur espoir
alors mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ma priorité est claire
favoriser le travail pour ceux qui en
sont éloignés sans rapproche en
soutenant ceux qui n'ont que le fruit de
leur travail pour vivre et qui sont
toujours au rendez-vous de leur
responsabilité mon CAP est clair c'est
celui de la souveraineté et de
l'indépendance à l'échelle individu elle
nationale et européenne ma méthode est
claire elle reste la même dire la vérité
même quand ça fait mal même quand cela
nous conduit à remettre en cause nos
propres décisions dire la vérité donc et
agir agir vraiment agir
maintenant monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
parler au français c'est entendre quatre
appels à l'action pour le travail pour
qu'il paye mieux et toujours plus que
l'inactivité partout et pour tous pour
nos services publics pour qu'il soit
accessible et de qualité partout et pour
tous pour l'autorité le civisme et le
respect des droits et des devoirs
partout et pour tous pour un
environnement plus respirable partout et
pour tous et je veux l'affirmer nous
n'avons pas renoncer aux grandes
conquête social et à la création de
droits nouveaux mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs pour le travail pour nos
services publics et le rétablissement de
l'autorité dans notre société pour la
transition écologique nous partons
aujourd'hui d'un bilan solide derrière
le cap fixé par le président de la
République nous avons multiplié les
actions et les réformes et je veux
rendre ici hommage à l'action
déterminante d'édoard Philippe de Jean
Castex et d'Élisabeth borne dont le sens
de l'État et la détermination à faire
sont des exemples je veux rendre hommage
à la majorité toujours mobilisé pour
améliorer le quotidien des Français je
veux saluer tous les parlementaires qui
ont accepté de sortir des logique
partisane pour permettre l'adoption de
nombreux textes aujourd'hui de premiers
résultats sont là depuis 2017 nous avons
montré que le chômage de masse n'était
pas une fatalité nous avons engagé des
réformes fortes qui avaient trop
longtemps été repoussées nous avons pris
les ordonnances travail dès le début du
premier quinquena nous avons mené une
réforme de l'assurance chômage une
réforme de l'apprentissage une réforme
des retraites nous avons lancé le
contrat d'engagement jeunes baisser les
impôts et les charges et engager une
réforme majeure du lycée professionnel
aujourd'hui le chômage a baissé de plus
de 2 points 2 millions d'emplois ont été
créés notre industrie revient avec
100000 emplois industriel créé et la
réouverture de 300 usines le nombre
d'apprentis a plus que triplé ils sont
désormais plus de 850000 et nous avons
le cap du million en
vue depuis 2017 nous avons agi
massivement pour nos services publics
pour notre santé avec les 19 milliards
de séure de la santé avec une
revalorisation historique des soignants
avec augmentation du nombre de places
dans les études de médecine d'infirmiers
et d'Aid soignants pour notre école nous
avons engagé des transformations majeur
et agit pour l'égalité des chances je
pense au dédoublement des classes ou
encore à l'augmentation du salaire des
enseignants la plus forte depuis 30
ans pour notre sécurité nous avons
investi comme jamais par le passé 10000
postes de policiers et de gendarmes ont
été créé lors du premier quinquena 8500
de plus le seront lors de celui-ci et
nous avons lancer la création de 238
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie la
sécurité ça doit être pour tous y
compris dans la ruralité et dans les
petites villes depuis 2017 pour la
planète nous avons préféré au grands mot
les vrais actes nous agissons et nous
agissons plus qu'aucune majorité avant
nous avant 2017 les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre diminué de 1 % en moyenne
par an dans le premier quinquena elles
ont baissé de 2 % en moyenne par an l'an
dernier sur les 9 premiers mois de
l'année elles ont baissé de près de 5 %
du président de la République nous avons
désormais une stratégie complète secteur
par secteur territoire par territoire la
planification écologique nous nous
donnons les moyens de réussir et nous
investissons cette année 40 milliards
d'euros pour la transition
écologique monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs nous
avons beaucoup fait mais il reste encore
du chemin avec mon gouvernement je je
suis prêt je suis déterminé nous devons
répondre aux inquiétudes de la classe
moyenne et faire en sorte que ceux qui
vont travailler puissent vivre leur
travail et gagne toujours plus que ceux
qui ne travaillent pas nous devons
répondre au défis des emplois non
pourvus car il est incompréhensible que
le chômage reste autour de 7 % alors
qu'il y a encore tant d'entreprises et
de filières qui cherchent à recruter
nous avons en France un paradoxe nous
avons un salaire minimum un SMIC
nettement supérieur à celui de nos
voisins et nous en sommes fiers mais
nous avons une part de nos travailleurs
proche du SMIC beaucoup plus importante
que nos voisins c'est un problème
d'abord nous agirons résolument pour que
les branches professionnelles qui
continuent à rémunérer en dessous du
SMIC remontent ces rémunérations c'était
le cas d'une soixantaine d'entre elles
l'an dernier grâce à la mobilisation
engagée alors nous étions descendus à
une trentaine à la fin de l'année 2023
la revalorisation du SMIC au 1er janvier
on a fait redescendre une partie en
dessous
je souhaite poursuivre et amplifier la
mobilisation pour des résultats rapides
et je n'exclus aucune mesure pour y
parvenir
ensuite nous devons faire évoluer un
système qui nous a conduit depuis des
décennies à concentrer nos aides et nos
exonérations au niveau du SMIC
aujourd'hui pour augmenter de 100 € le
revenu d'un employé au SMIC l'employeur
devra débourser 238 € de plus quant au
salarié il perdra 39 € de prime
d'activité verra sa CSG ses cotisations
sociales de 26 € et pourrait payer
l'impôt sur le revenu en bref autant le
dire notre système fruit de réformes
successives pé de bonnes intentions ces
dernières années a placé notre monde
économique dans une situation où il n'y
a quasiment plus aucun intérêt pour
quiconque à augmenter un salarié
SMIC on ne peut accepter une France où
beaucoup sont condamné à rester proche
du SMIC toute leur carrière la
progression salariale doit toujours
permettre de penser l'effort et le
mérite oui j'assume de le dire il faut
désmicardiser la France dès le prochain
lo projet loi de finance en nous
appuyant sur les propositions des
parlementaires des partenaires sociaux
et sur un certain nombre de travaux
d'experts qui sont actuellement conduit
nous commencerons à réformer ce système
dans le même temps nous devons continuer
à baisser les charges qui pèsent sur la
classe moyenne après la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation de la revance
télévision après la baisse de 5
milliards d'euros des premières l'impôt
sur le revenu nous tiendrons
l'engagement du président de la
République d'une nouvelle baisse d'impôt
de 2 milliards d'euros cette baisse
d'impôt sera financé et la solidarité
nationale devra s'exercer pour nos
classes
moyennes valoriser le travail ce n'est
pas seulement pour les salariés nous
agirons aussi pour nos fonctionnaires
qui permettent à l'état d'avancer et
s'engagent au service de l'intérêt
général en intégrant leurs mérites et
leurs efforts à leur rémunération un
projet de loi sur sera déposé dès le
second semestre de cette année deuxème
objectif pour réussir je veux
déverrouiller l'accès au travail
déverrouiller notre société je veux
permettre à tous ceux qui le peuvent de
travailler avec en tête les droits et
les devoirs de chacun le droit d'être
mieux accompagné grâce à la réforme de
France travail mais aussi le devoir de
chercher un emploi dans 18 départements
nous avons lancé une expérimentation qui
conditionne le RSA à 15h d'activité pour
la insertion je vous annonce que nous
généraliserons ce dispositif à tous les
départements de France d'ici le 1er
janvier
2025 de plus nous devons aller plus loin
dans la réforme de l'assurance chômage
une négociation a été lancée en faveur
de l'emploi des seniors de la prévention
de usur professionnell des parcours et
des reconversions et nous souhaitons
qu'elle aboutisse un résultat
ambitieux mais la situation économique
évolue parce que nous gardons notre
objectif de plein emploi et que nous
devons inciter toujours plus à la
reprise du travail je serais extrêmement
attentif à l'évolution de la trajectoire
financière de l'assurance chômage si
cette dernière dévie je n'hésiterai pas
comme la loi le permet à demander aux
partenaires sociaux de remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier sur la base
d'une nouvelle lettre de cadrage autour
d'une ambition très claire inciter
toujours plus à la reprise du travail
sans
tout nous combattrons également toutes
les trappes à inactivité d'un côté en
rendant les droits effectifs nous avons
été capables de faire le prélèvement à
la source nous serons capables de mener
à bien la solidarité à la source pour
éviter les démarches inutiles et
garantir la pleine justice sociale que
chacun touche l'intégralité de ce à quoi
il a droit combattre les trappes à une
activité c'est assumer de réinterroger
notre modèle je pense notamment à
l'odocation de solidarité spécifique qui
prolonge l'indemnisation du chômage et
qui permet sans travailler de valider
les trimestres de retraite or la
retraite doit toujours rester le fruit
du travail je proposerai sa
suppression chercher un modèle social
plus efficace et moins coûteux ce n'est
pas un gros mot c'est un
impératif déverrouiller le travail c'est
aussi d'adapter aux nouvelles
aspirations de nos concitoyens c'est un
fait le rapport au travail a changé je
mesure dans ma génération comme dans les
autres les changements de mentalité les
attentes nouvelles sur les horaires sur
la disponibilité sur l'équilibre entre
vie professionnelle et vie familiale ces
aspirations ne doivent pas être niées
elles ne doivent pas être caricaturé non
plus au risque de décevoir certains ici
personne de demande de droit à lappisse
non ces aspirations elles doivent être
regardé pour ce qu'elles sont notre
rapport au travail c'est notre rapport
au temps à l'équilibre personnel on ne
peut pas appliquer les mêmes calques
génération après génération les attentes
changent les technologies évoluent et
font paraître de nouvelles fractures
notamment entre ceux qui peuvent
télétravailler et ceux qui ne le peuvent
pas alors les conditions de travail
doivent évoluer aussi et l'État doit
donner l'exemple comme ministre des
comptes publs j'avais décidé contre van
et Maré d'expérimenter dans mon
administration non pas la semaine de 4
jours mais la semaine en 4 jours sans
réduction du temps de travail à certains
endroits il y a eu peu de candidats
d'autres ils sont nombreux avoir choisi
d'arriver plus tôt le matin de partir
plus tard le soir pour travailler un
jour de moin comme premier ministre je
demande à l'ensemble de mes ministres
d'expérimenter cette solution dans leurs
administrations centrales et
déconcentrer
oui l'État doit donner l'exemple
s'agissant de l'organisation du travail
notamment pour toutes ces personnes qui
travaillent dur et se sentent invisible
je pense notamment aux personnes du
ménage parfois forcées à faire des
heures de transport en commun au milieu
de la nuit tout ça pour éviter qu'elle
ne travaille en même temps que les
salariés là aussi je veux que l'État
montre l'exemple et que désormais dans
l'état les personnels d'entretien de
l'administration qui le souhaitent
puissent travailler aux mêmes horaires
que tout le monde aux horaires de
bureau oui nous devons mieux prendre en
compte notre rapport au temps et nous
continuerons à avancer dans le chantier
du compte épargne de temps universel
véritable sac às social qui doit
permettre à ceux qui le souhaitent de
travailler beaucoup plus à certains
moments de leur vie où ils le peuvent
notamment quand ils sont jeunes et nont
pas encore de responsabilité familiale
pour pouvoir travailler moins à d'autres
moments de leur vie pour développer un
projet
s'occuper de leur famille ou d'un proche
qui en a besoin déverrouiller notre
économie c'est aussi conquérir de
nouvelles libertés refuser le principe
de rente et être capable de continuer à
transformer et libérer un projet de loi
en ce sens sera examiné au printemps il
permettra notamment de déverrouiller
certaines professions comme les syndices
ou encore les ventes en ligne de
médicament par les
pharmacies mesdames et messieurs les
députés beaucoup d'entre vous dit
sénateur si est un secteur qu'il faut
déverrouiller c'est le
logement le problème du logement est
clair il tient à la fois à l'offre et à
la demande or pouvoir se loger acquérir
son logement c'est pourtant de français
le projet d'une vie l'assuranceune
retraite
sereine en lien avec les élus locaux
nous répondrons à cette crise du
logement en créant un choc d'offre avec
C solutions nous allons simplifier
massivement les normes revoir les DPE
simplifier l'accès prime renove
faciliter la densification lever les
contraintes sur le zonage accélérer les
procédures nous désignerons dans 2
semaines 20 territoire engagé par le
logement où nous accélérerons toutes les
procédures comme nous avons su le faire
pour l'organisation des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques avec comm objectif d'y
créer 30000 nouveaux logements d'ici 3
ans n'hésiterons pas à procéder à des
réquisitions pour les bâtiments vides
notamment des bâtiments de bureau nous
l'avons déjà fait et nous continuerons
nous continuerons à soutenir le monde du
logement social nous avons agi pour lui
en maintenant le taux du livret A avec
1,2 milliard d'euros pour le rénovation
énergétique avec des plans de rachat
massif nous voulons également répondre
au CA structurel de la crise le coût
élevé du foncier avec un nouveau prêt de
très long terme 2 milliards d'euros
distribu par la banque des territoires
et nous allons aussi le faire évoluer le
faire évoluer pour inciter les élus à
développer de nouveaux programmes aussi
je vous annonce que nous allons donner
au maires la main pour la première
attribution dans les nouveaux logements
sociaux construits sur leur commune
c'était une mesure très attendue par les
élus
locaux le faire évoluer aussi pour
soutenir les classes moyennes vous le
savez d'ici 2025 toutes les communes
soumises à la loi SRU doivent posséder
au moins un/4 de logements sociaux sur
territoire nous proposerons d'ajouter
pour une part les logements
intermédiaires accessibles à la classe
moyenne dans ce
calqu mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs désmicardisé pour promouvoir
le travail déverrouillé pour libérer
l'initiative et la croissance je veux
aussi débureaucratiser la France je veux
alléger le fardeau des règles des normme
qui pèse sur ceux qui créent nos TPE et
nos PME surtout ces Français qui
travaillent sans cré l'activité de
l'emploi il a été évalué que chaque
année ce sont 60 milliards d'euros que
nous perdons à cause de ces démarches et
des complexité notre quotidien aussi
nous engagerons après l'été une nouvelle
étape de la réforme du droit du travail
avec un objectif clair libérer les
énergies de nos PME et de nos TPE
simplifier considérablement leur
quotidien et leur permettre de négocier
certaines règles directement entreprise
par entreprise mais cet élan de
simplification ne doit pas se limiter au
travail partout dans notre pays les
Français me racontent combien les normes
les oppressent les brides les empêche de
faire et d'avancer je pense à nos
agriculteurs je pense à tous les petits
patrons je pense à nos élus locaux qui
croulent sous des règles et des
procédures administratives à date le
nombre de mots pour dire des normes sur
lesgif France s'élève à 44,1 millions de
mots c'est pratiquement deux fois plus
qu'il y a 20 ans à tous les échelons je
veux débureaucratiser la France nous
évaluerons les normes qui peuvent être
supprimé ou simplifié les Français les
professionnels avec les élus nous
regarderons les démarches qui peuvent
être améliorées tous les sujets sont sur
la table mon seul objectif c'est de
libérer les Français c'est de les
laisser vivre et respirer supprimer des
normes c'est possible vendredi dernier
j'ai annoncé la suppression de 10 normes
national pour nos agriculteurs et
beaucoup d'autres suivront au niveau
local en Garon en quelques réunions sur
une semaine le préfet et les
agriculteurs se sont accordés sur
l'abrogation de quatre arrêtés
préfectoraux cette logique est étendue
dès cette semaine à l'ensemble du pays
simplifier des démarches c'est possible
et je vous annonce que dès cette année
chacun pourra enfin porter plainte en
ligne partout sur le
territoire simplifier pour éviter la
gabgie c'est possible et je vous annonce
une règle générale tous les organes
comités et autres qui ne se sont pas
réunis ces 12 derniers mois seront
supprimés enfin des P entiers de notre
économie demandent des simplifications
encore drastiques notamment pour
accélérer le retour de notre industrie
pourquoi parce que trop de délais c'est
moins de projet et donc moins d'emploi
et moins de croissance quand un
investisseur veut implanter un projet en
Europe quelque chose saute aux yeux en
France il faut 17 mois en moyenne pour
implanter un projet industriel en
Allemagne c'est deux fois moins
avec le projet de loi industrie verte
nous avons marqué une première étape je
vous annonce que nous déposerons un
deuxième projet de loi industrie verte
il proposera notamment de concentrer les
travaux de la CNDP uniquement sur les
projets d'envergure national c'est 6
mois de gagner dans les
procédures la bureaucratie recule c'est
la liberté qui avance je veux libérer
les Français des contraintes qui les
freinent et sont autant de boulet pour
notre économie monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
déverrouiller désnicardisé
débureaucratisé oui mais dans un seul
objectif r réarmer notre
pays je veux le dire
d'emblé le préalable du réarmement de la
France c'est la responsabilité
budgétaire nous devons faire preuve
d'une responsabilité exemplaire dans nos
finances publiques il en va de notre
souveraineté il en va de la survie de
notre modèle social il en va de la
protection des plus fragiles et des
classes moyennes qui seraient les
premières victimes des coupes massives
et des hausses drastiques auxquelles
nous sers contraints si nous ne tenons
pas notre trajectoire de réduction de
nos déficits et notre dette et je le dis
pour nous le meilleur moyen de réduire
nos déficits c'est le travail et la
croissance pour certains la croissance
est un gros mot et on a que le mot taxé
à la bouche tout y est passé dans les
propositions parlementaires ces
dernières années les heures
supplémentaires des ouvriers le
patrimoine des retraités et même les
successions des petits agriculteurs à
cela je le réaffirme quand on taxe tout
très vite il n'y a plus rien à taxer et
on ne taxe plus rien du tout je vous
confirme que nous tiendrons le même cap
repasser sous les 3 % de déficit public
d'ici 2027 grâce à plus de croissance
plus d'activité et à la maîtrise de nos
dépenses pas grâce à trop d'impôts grâce
à des économies de structure aussi nous
mettrons toutes nos forces dans la
bataille nous allons poursuivre et
renforcer les revues de dépenses auquels
tous les ministères et tous les secteurs
de l'action publique ser seront associé
les premières propositions d'économie
pour le prochain PLF issu de ce travail
seront annoncé dès le mois de mars et je
souhaite qu'elle donne lieu très vite à
des échanges avec la représentation
nationale monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs cEIT armement
que nous construisons avec le président
de la République il a un objectif
prioritaire assurer notre souveraineté
alors oui nous continuerons à renforcer
notre souveraineté nationale où nos
frontières sont respectées la lutte
contre l'immigration illégale doit
continuer à s'intensifier il faut
assumer d'accueillir moins pour
accueillir mieux nous continuerons à
déployer la border force lancée dans les
alpes maritimes qui a déjà permis près
de 45000 interprellations à la frontière
italienne je tiendrai l'engagement de ma
prédécesseur de réformer l'aide médicale
d'État nous le ferons avant l'été par la
voie réglementaire avec une base qui est
connue le rapport evvin
stéphanini défendre notre souveraineté
nationale c'est aussi donner les moyens
nécessaires à nos armées pour protéger
notre territoire et nos valeurs nos
militaires se battent au péril de leur
vie pour défendre notre pays notre
République et dans le cadre de la loi de
programmation militaire nous tiendrons
nos engagements vis-à-vis d'eux avec
vous toutes et tous je veux rendre
hommage aux femmes et aux hommes de nos
armées rendre hommage à ceux qui sont
tombés pour nous défendre leur sacrifice
nous oblige notre reconnaissance est
infinie notre souveraineté c'est aussi
notre capacité à répondre aux besoins de
nos concitoyens et donc sur ces
fondements nous allons réarmer nos
services publics ils ont toujours été
une fierté ils doivent le
redevenir nous allons continuer à
réarmer notre système de santé et avec
vous je veux rendre hommage à tous les
soignants de France chacun leur poste
chacun dans leur spécialité Ils sont les
visages de l'engagement et de
l'accompagnement de l'attention et de
l'humanité aujourd'hui quel est le
problème malgré le travail des soignants
le temps médical manque nos compatriotes
ne trouvent pas de médecins et les
délais aux urgences se rallongent cela
se traduit par la désertification de
notre pays et par la saturation de nos
hôpitaux l'objectif est clair plus de
temps médical premier pilier agir pour
qu'il y ait plus de médecins devant les
les effets de la suppression du numérus
closus ne se feront pas sentir
immédiatement alors nous allons mettre
en vre des solutions fortes tout de
suite c'est pourquoi comme l'annoncé le
président de la République nous
procéderons à la régularisation des
médecins étrangers sur notre
territoire c'est pourquoi aussi je vous
l'annonce je nommerai un émissaire
chargé d'aller chercher à l'étranger des
médecins qui voudrai venir exercer en
France nous devons trouver des moyens de
faire revenir nos jeunes Français parti
étudier la médecine à
l'étranger nous devons aussi et c'est ce
qu'a proposé le député neuder mieux
reconnaître l'expertise et la volonté de
soignants qui ont fait beaucoup d'études
et ont une vraie expérience une
infirmière anesthésiste qui a un bac + 5
plusieurs années de carrière et
d'expérience doit pouvoir si elle le
souhaite entrer directement au moins en
3è année de
médecine deè pilier agir pour qu'il n'y
ait aucun territoire oublié nous avons
depuis 2017 déployé le service d'accès
aux soins il permet un progrès notable
dans l'accès aux soins non programmés je
l'ai vu encore récemment à 10jon dès cet
été chaque département devra être doté
d'un service d'accès aux soins avec des
professionnels organisés pour assurer la
permanence des soins dans les
départements il n'y aurait toujours pas
de service d'accès aux soins des
réponses satisfaisantes je suis prêt à
aller plus loin en restaurant des
obligations de garde pour les médecins
libéraux en soirée ou le weekend dans
leur cabinet à l'hôpital ou en maison de
santé 3è pilier libérer les médecins
pour qu'ils se concentrent sur le soin
nous poursuivrons les chantiers que nous
avons engagés notamment pour
l'attractivité de tous les métiers de
soins nous allons accélérer le passage
de 6000 à 10000 assistants médicaux qui
permettront au médecins de pouvoir se
consacrer davantage aux patients et
moins aux formalités administratives
cela représentera 2,5 millions de
consultations libérales tous les ans
pour les patients
ensuite nous allons poursuiv notre
action en faveur de l'hôpital les moyens
du séure de la santé ne sont pas encore
arrivés partout ses lourdeurs et ses
lenteurs sont insupportables je veux que
cela change rapidement enfin il y a
encore aujourd'hui trop de rendez-vous
médicaux qui ne sont pas honorés pour
les médecins il est insupportable
d'avoir chaque jour des patients qui ont
un rendez-vous et qui ne se présente pas
pour les Français il est insupportable
de savoir que des millions d'heures sont
perdus alors qu'ils attendent parfois
des mois pour un rendez-vous je souhaite
un principe simple qui se traduise par
des mesures claires de cette année quand
on a un rendez-vous chez le médecin et
qu'on ne vient pas sans prévenir on
paye protéger nos concitoyens c'est
aussi les accompagner à tous les âges de
la vie et à toutes les étapes de la vie
nous continuerons à agir pour l'enfance
notamment l'enfance en danger nous
continuerons à bâtir une société où
chacun peut vieillir dignement et comme
il l'entend en facilitant le maintien à
domicile de ceux qui le souhaitent et en
améliorant le quotidien en épad le défi
financier et humain est
immense mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs parler de santé c'est trop
souvent oublier la santé mentale le
mal-être les dépressions les pensées
suicidaires ont beaucoup progressé chez
nos jeunes je veux faire de la santé
mentale notre jeunesse une grande cause
de notre action gouvernementale avec là
aussi des mesures claires et
immédiates d'abord réformer le
dispositif mon soutien PSI il faut être
lucide ce dispositif partait d'une bonne
intention mais il n'a pas donné les
résultat escomptés je vous annonce donc
que nous allons le rénover de fond en
comble nous allons augmenter le tarif de
la consultation rembourser pour limiter
au maximum le reste à charge pour les
jeunes patients et pour leurs familles
pour lever tous les verrous nous
permettrons aussi aux jeunes d'avoir
accès directement à un psychologue sans
nécessairement passer par un médecin de
plus nous devons mailler le territoire
de Maison départementale des adolescents
il y en a 50 aujourd'hui je souhaite
qu'il y en ait une par
département pour la santé notamment la
santé psychologique les infirmières
scolaires sont des relais essentiels
auprès des élèves elles accomplissent un
travail remarquable elles accompagnent
les jeunes avec disponibilité écoute et
soins
nous devons recruter davantage
d'infirmières scolaires et mieux
reconnaître leur
engagement aussi je vous annonce que
grâce à un budget supplémentaire issu
d'un amendement porté par les groupes de
la majorité dans le dernier budget j'ai
décidé de leur verser en mai prochain
une prime exceptionnelle de 800 € et de
revaloriser leur salaire de 200 € nets
par mois en moyenne à compter de cette
date je demande également au
gouvernement de travailler à des
revalorisations pour les autres
personnes et sanitair en milieu scolaire
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs renforcer nos
services publics c'est aussi agir pour
notre école je veux rendre ici hommage à
nos professeurs ils s'investissent tous
les jours au service de notre école de
nos élèves et donc de notre pays j'ai
souvent dit ma fierté d'êre leur
ministre et aujourd'hui comme premier
ministre je n'oublie rien de ce que nous
leur devons je serai toujours à leur
côté je dit dès mes premières minutes
comme premier ministre l'école est la
mère des batailles sur l'école là aussi
il faut partir de la réalité des faites
pas besoin des études internationales
pour cela que nous disent les parents
les grandspents d'élèves que ces
dernières décennies le niveau a baissé
que si le nombre d'heures d'absence
remplacé à triplé ces derniers mois le
compte n est toujours pas que nous
disent les professeurs qu'ils croient en
leur métier mais qu'il est de plus en
plus difficile à exercer quils ont
parfois peur d'enseigner des P entiers
de notre histoire ou de notre
littérature que nous disent les jeunes
qui envisagent de devenir enseignants
que la formation initiale telle qu'elle
a été organisée ne correspond pas à
leurs attentes et freine leurs vocation
nous allons continuer à leur répondre
pour élever le niveau des élèves j'ai
lancé le choc des savoirs et doit
maintenant se déployer le choc des
savoir c'est assumer que tout le monde
ne progresse pas au même rythme que tout
le monde n'a pas les mêmes facilités ou
les mêmes difficulté la décision du
redoublement sera désormais à la main de
l'équipe pédagogique et les groupes de
niveau commenceront à se mettre en place
dès cette année dans nos collèges une
école du passage automatique c'est une
école où tout le monde stagne et où le
niveau baisse nous assumons de porter
une école des savoirs de l'excellence où
chacun apprend à son rythme améliorer
les savoir c'est aussi veiller à ce que
chaque jour de l'année chaque heure de
cours chaque élève est un professeur
face à lui
nous évaluerons le PACT enseignant et si
de nouvelles mesures s'imposent nous les
prendrons sans
tabout veiller au niveau des élèves
c'est réagir face au nouveaux défis qui
les menaces les écrans sont une
catastrophe éducative et sanitaire en
puissance nous avons d'ors et déjà
interdit le portable au collège et comme
l'a annoncé le président de la
République nous travaillerons à mieux
réguler l'usage des écran dans et en
dehors de l'école j'ajoute qu'une école
des savoirs c'est aussi une école qui
permet de projeter dans l'avenir
désormais tous les élèves de secondde
devront faire un stage de de semaines
nous continuerons à rapprocher l'école
et les métiers une école qui fonctionne
c'est une école où les professeurs sont
mieux formés nous réformerons la
formation des enseignants pour
construire les écoles normales du 21e
siècle cette réforme sera présentée
d'ici au mois de mars une école qui
marche est aussi une école où les élèves
sont heureux trop longtemps le bien-être
des élèves est resté un impensé le
résultat nous le connaissons ce sont
notamment les drames du harcèlement
notre stratégie contre le harcèlement
qui a permis de briser des tabous
majeurs et très concrèes désormais c'est
l'élève harceleur qui doit quitter
l'école plus l'élève victime qui subit
une double peine j'en suis
fier le bien-être à l'école c'est aussi
donner toute leur place aux élèves en
situation de handicap bâtir une société
inclusive est au cœur des priorités de
mon gouvernement cela vaut dans tous les
domaines j'y serai très attentif nous
accompagnerons nos concitoyens en
situation de handicap en toute
circonstance nous leur simplifierons la
vie nous prendrons intégralement en
charge de remboursement des fauteuils
roulants de ceux qui en ont besoin nous
agirons partout et particulièrement à
l'école depuis des années l'État les
collectivités se renvoi la balle sur la
prise en charge des aosh sur la pause du
midi résultat dans beaucoup endroit
personne ne les finance et la
conséquence c'est une double défaite des
élèves pas suffisamment bien accompagnés
au moment du repas et des aesh qui ne
peuvent faire un temps complet pour
améliorer leur rémunération il faut
sortir de cette situation et je prends
une décision claire l'État prend ses
responsabilités et financera désormais
l'accompagnement des enfants en
situation de handicap sur leur pause
déjeuner c'est un enjeu de solidarité de
dignité de
reconnaissance
réarmer notre école c'est réaffirmer nos
valeurs car je crois que la transmission
du savoir est impossible sans respect de
l'autorité sans respect de nos valeurs
républicaines au premier rang desquels
la laïcité on ne négocie pas avec la
République on l'accepte et on la
respecte en entier sans mais sans la
moindre
exception c'est pourquoi nous soutenons
l'expérimentation de l'uniforme à
l'école symbole d'égalité républicaine
et comme l'aannoncé le président de la
République si cette expérimentation est
concluante nous généraliserons
l'uniforme en France à la rentrée
2026 je veux le dire également je ne
peux pas me résoudre à ce que certains
professeurs craignent d'aborder certains
chapitre du programme à la moindre
entorse notre pacte républicain il doit
y avoir des décisions fortes et des
sanctions fermes l'école sera le fer de
l'Ance du rement civique demandé par le
Président de la République comme comme
il s'y est engagé le nombre d'heures
d'instruction civique sera doublé au
collège Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénateur réussir le réarmement civique
c'est au cœur des priorités de mon
gouvernement nous devons faire respecter
l'utorité partout dans les classes dans
les familles dans les rues ce respect
s'apprend à l'école je le disais ce
respect de l'autorité passe aussi par
les familles les violences de juillet
dernier ont profondément marqué notre
pays parmi les éémetiers des jeunes très
jeunes parfois qui semblaient avoir déjà
coupé les ponts avec notre société qui
ne respectent plus leurs parents ou pour
qui la violence semble un moyen comme un
autre de tromper l'ennui je ne me
résoudrai jamais ce qu'on préfère
attendre avant de donner une lourde
peine alors que bien souvent c'est très
tôt qu'il aurait fallu agir nous devons
disposer de sanctions adaptées pour les
mineurs de moins de 16 ans pour eux on
ne peut pas aujourd'hui prononcer de
peine de travaux d'intérêt général je
vous annonce que nous créerons des
travaux d'intérêt éducatif qui seront
leurs équivalents et seront donnés plus
facilement que des peines d'intérêt
général cela fera partie d'une revue de
l'échelle des sanctions dans nos
établissements scolaires dès le plus
jeune âge il faut en revenir à un
principe simple tu casses tu répares tu
salies tu nettoies tu défies l'autorité
tu apprend à
respecter nous responsabiliserons aussi
davantage les parents
dans le cadre d'un projet de loi de
justice sur la justice des mineurs nous
soutiendrons la mise en place de travaux
d'intérêt général pour les parents de
jeunes délinquants qui se sont
totalement soustraits à leur
responsabilité
parentale mais je le dis il est hors de
question d'accabler certaines familles
quand on est une mère seule de plusieurs
enfants dans un quartier on peut-être
totalement dépassé par les événements et
on n'est pas toujours responsable de la
dérive de ses enfants pour elle au
contraire cette dérive est un échec et
une douleur terrible nous devons les
aider songez que nous avons en France
50000 places d'internat
disponibles aussi désormais quand un
jeune sera sur la mauvaise pente plutôt
que de le laisser plonger dans la
délinquence nous proposerons aux parents
de le placer en internat en y facilitant
l'accès y compris financier nous allons
le couper de ces mauvaises
fréquentations nous allons lui offrir un
cadre un enseignement et une chance le
réement civique c'est bien entendu le
respect de la loi nos concitoyens
attendent de nous que nous agissions
encore et toujours contre les violences
les trafics les cambriolages contre
l'insécurité du quotidien et la
délinquence il demande de l'ordre dans
nos rues tout n'est pas une question de
moyens il faut les mettre au service
d'une stratégie plus offensive encore
comme l'a dit le président de la
République nous allons doubler la
présence policière dans les rues d'ici
2030 nous allons mener des actions
coordonnées de tous les service de
l'État force de l'éducation services
sociaux dans certains quartiers c'est le
sens des forces d'action républicaines
nous les déploierons fin février dans
trois premiers territoires à maubeugge
Valence et
beuganon contre l'insécurité nous nous
sommes fixés deux priorités la lutte
contre les stupéfiants et la lutte
contre la délinquence du quotidien en
particulier les cambriolages nous allons
encore monter d'un cran dans notre
combat contre la drogue en mettant en
œuvre un nouveau plan de lutte contre
les stupéfiants notre stratégie de
harcèlement de pilonnage contre les
dealers part ses fruits nous avons
réussi à faire disparaître un quart des
points de Deal alors nous allons
poursuivre avec 10 opérations place net
par semaine nous devons aussi taper les
dealers au porte-monnaie le couper les
vivres c'est pourquoi je vous annonce
nous allons désormais geler les avoirs
des trafiquants de drogue
identifiés notre rement civique passe
par une justice plus rapide et plus
efficace ensemble nous allons envoyer un
message clair l'impunité c'est fini nous
avons décidé de moyens exceptionnels
pour notre justice ils seront au
rendez-vous nous allons améliorer le
fonctionnement de la justice avec plus
de magistrats et de greffiers avec une
organisation plus respectueuse de nos
concitoyens et une nouveauté désormais
les Français ne seront plus convoqués
sur des créneaux pouvant courir sur une
demi-journée entière mais sur un créneau
horaire bien défini c'est aussi par ce
type de mesure et preuve de respect que
l'on renoue le lien entre la justice et
les
justiciables enfin notre réarmement
civique c'est renforcer l'unité
républicaine de notre jeunesse c'est
permettre à tous les jeunes de France de
faire nation c'est le rôle même du
service national universel je lance les
travaux en vue de sa généralisation la
rentrée scolaire
2026 mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs parler de nos services publics
c'est aussi parler de nos territoires
chacun n'a pas les mêmes défis les mêmes
attentes les mêmes besoins j'évoquerai
demain longuement devant le Sénat ma
stratégie pour nos territoires je veux
néanmoins d'ors et déjà vous assurer que
mon gouvernement sera toujours à
l'écoute des territoires et des élus
locaux que toutes nos solutions se
construiront avec eux je peux vous
assurer aussi que nous chercherons
toujours des solutions adaptées aux
réalité du terrain en ayant recours à la
différenciation à l'adaptation des me
nous chercherons ensemble un chemin pour
une autonomie de la Corse dans la
République comme si est engagé le
président de la
République mais alors que je parle de
différenciation j'ai une pensée pour les
territoires d'outrem où elle s'impose
tout particulièrement il réarmé nos
services publics il est peut-être encore
plus crucial plus vital
qu'ailleurs les outremers sont un atout
déterminant pour notre pays il y a dans
chaque territoire d'outremer l'ous as
notre jeunesse et la détermination à
réussir l'avenir mais nous autres ma
concentrre aussi tous les défis contre
la vichè pour l'emploi pour la sécurité
pour la santé l'école la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale et la transition
écologique chacune de nos politiques
publiques doit tenir compte des
spécificités des outr m j'y tiens et
pour faire face aux enjeux exceptionnels
auquel son territoire est confronter
nous déposerons une loi sur
Mayotte je veux avoir ici un mot
particulier pour la Nouvelle Calédonie
je souhaite que le processus politique
en cours aboutisse j'y veillerai et vous
examinerez dans quelques semaines un
projet de loi constitutionnel sur
l'avenir de la nouvelle
caédonie monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs ensemble je
vous propose d'accélérer encore notre
transition
écologique le dérèglement climatique ce
ne sont pas seulement quelques degrés de
plus ce sont des vies détruites par les
intempéries ce sont des exploitations
agricoles menacé avec elle toute notre
capacité à nous nourrir ce sont des
maisons des immeubles menacés par la
montée des eaux fissurés par les
mouvements des sols face à ces constats
certains voudraient une écologie de la
brutalité pour eux l'écologie doit être
punitive douloureuse passé par la
désignation de bouc émissa et par la
décroissance la décroissance c'est la
fin de notre modèle social c'est la
pauvreté de masses jamais je ne
l'accepterai je crois au contraire qu'on
ne a pas l'écologie contre le peuple je
crois au contraire qu'il faut entendre
les inquiétudes des Français de tous les
Français il faut entendre les
agriculteurs qui s'inquiètent de
l'avenir de leur métier il faut entendre
les élus locaux qui veulent développer
leur commune il faut entendre les
millions de Français des villes moyennes
des petites communes et de la ruralité
pour qui la voiture et gage de travail
et de liberté l'écologie sans le peuple
s pavé le chemin aux crises sociales et
au renoncement
au contraire nous allons continuer à
bâtir ensemble une écologie populaire
une écologie à la française avec les
Français et pour les Français c'est tout
le chans de la planification écologique
qui protègera la biodiversité et
permettra une baisse radicale de nos gaz
à effet de ser de 55 % d'ici
2030 une écologie populaire c'est une
écologie où chacun agit à la hauteur de
ses moyens c'est pourquoi l'État sera
exemplaire c'est pourquoi nous
continuerons d'aider les entreprise a
participé massivement à l'effort je suis
fier que les 50 sites industriels les
plus émetteurs 50 sites qui représentent
à eu seul 10 % des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre en France se soi tous
engagés à réduire leurs émissions de
près de moitié d'ici 2030 je vous
annonce que nous lancerons une
initiative similaire contre la pollution
plastique pour les 50 sites qui mettent
le plus d'emballage plastiqu sur le
marché une écologie populaire c'est une
écologie des solutions le président de
la République s'était engagé à lancer
une offre de véhicule électrique pour
moins de 100 € par mois cet engagement
est tenu et le succès est au rendez-vous
le président de la République s'était
engagé à développer les rir
métropolitains et investir massivement
dans le ferroviaire cet engagement lue
aussi nous le
tiendrons une écologie populaire c'est
une écologie de la croissance et de
l'emploi le retour de l'industrie les
investissements en faveur de la
décarbonation grâce à France 2030 les
métiers de la rénovation thermique
pourou le secteur de l'économie
circulaire la transition écologique
regorge d'opportunités de secteurs en
croissance et de filières nouvelles oui
nous ferons rimer climat avec
croissance une écologie populaire c'est
une écologie qui se construit au plus
près des réalités des Français et des
territoires des concertations sont en
cours partout en France au côté des élus
locaux nous donnerons chacun les moyens
de faire et je souhaite que le
financement de leurs plans locaux de
transition écologique soit établi
partout d'ici
l'été une écologie populaire c'est une
écologie qui protège et assure notre
souveraineté grâce à la sobriété aux
énergies renouvelables au nucléairire
nous allons assurer notre indépendance
énergétique je veux le dire sans ambigué
le nucléaire est une fierté française le
nucléaire est un atout majeur pour notre
pays j'assume pleinement d'être à la
tête d'un gouvernement pro énergie
nucléaire nous allons continuer la mise
en puissance notre parc nucléaire
investir massivement dans les programmes
et cette année le pè de flamandville
sera
opérationnel c'est aussi grâce au
nucléaire que nous pvons garantir les
meilleurs prix aux Français nous
protégerons mieux les consommateurs et
réguleront les prix de l'électricité
afin qu'il se rapproche des coûts de
production enfin mesdames et messieurs
les députés bâtir une écologie populaire
c'est répondre aux séndateurs aux
aspirations de notre
jeunesse réussir la transition ique est
le défi de notre génération notre
jeunesse veut s'engager participer aider
elle se demande comment être utile pour
la planète c'est pourquoi nous lancerons
un service civique écologique qui
rassemblera d'ici la fin du quinena
50000 jeunes prêts à s'engager
concrètement pour le
climat j'ajoute que si nous devons
réduire nos émissions et protéger notre
biodiversité nous devons aussi nous
adapter au dérèglement climatique nous
adapter nous préparer c'est veiller à ce
que chacun même est plus fragile soit
prêt face au ravage du dérèglement
climatique nous présenterons dès ce
trimestre un nouveau plan d'adaptation
au changement climatique il présentera
des solutions adaptées à chaque
territoire notamment dans les outr mers
enfin je vous annonce que nous ferons
évoluer le régime de catastrophe
naturelle pour le moderniser et éviter
que certains assureurs n'abandonnent les
territoires les plus à
risque enfin je l'ai déjà évoqué je
tenais venir nous devons mener notre
réarmement
agricole produire et protéger pour notre
souveraineté voilà mon approche depuis
2017 nous avons engagé ce combat de la
souveraineté du revenu c'est le sens des
plans de filière des différentes lois
égalim du varen de l'eau nous avons
développé 250 millions d'euros pour
trouver des alternatives au pesticides
c'est un effort inédit sur l'Union
européenne nous avons toujours été
moteur sur la réciprocité des clauses
miroir et nous les ferons resp
produire c'est d'abord donner du temps à
nos agriculteurs pour passer plus de
temps dans leurs champs et moins devant
leurs écrans produire c'est être
souverain je souhaite que cet objectif
de souveraineté alimentaire soit
clairement inscrit dans la loi protéger
aussi protégé face aux crises
climatiques et sanitair le gouvernement
l'a toujours fait lors du gel des
sécheresses de la grippe aviaire nous
avons adopté une réforme de l'assurance
récolte sans précédent avec un budget
historique nous continuons à le faire
protéger face à la concurrence déloyale
c'est le combat pour la réciprocité de
mesur miroir que je vais continuer à
mener avec détermination ce combat doit
se mener en Europe comme nous l'avons
fait sur les médicaments vétérinaires
mais nous devons aller plus loin changer
de logique j'assume de dire que tout ne
sera pas réglé en quelques semaines
j'assume de dire que les chantiers sont
complexes et que pour certains il faudra
travailler encore et encore j'assume
aussi d'apporter des réponses rapides
partout là où c'est possible très
concrètement sur egalim dès la semaine
dernière 100 inspecteurs de la DGCCRF
supplémentaire ont commencé leur
contrôle sur le terrain qui seront deux
fois plus nombreux qu'auparavant c'est
une vague de contrôle sans précédent sur
la trésorerie des exploitants nous
avançons dès la semaine prochaine dès
février 50 % du remboursement titicpe
sera versé aux exploitants soit 733 €
par exemple pour une exploitation
utilisant 7000 l de GNR dès la semaine
prochaine le 5 février précisément un
guichet pour la prise en charge des
frais vétérinaires concernant la MHE
sera ouvert il permettra de verser des
premières indemnisations dès la fin du
mois de février le taux de prise en
charge des frais vétérinaires a été
réévalué à
90% d'ici le 15 mars toutes les a PAC
seront versées sur les comptes bancaires
des exploitants et nous travaillerons
avec les régions pour que les aides à
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
puissent être versées dans les
prochaines semaines et la semaine
dernière le fond d'urgence Bretagne a
été
doublé sur la simplification 10 normes
sont simplifiées et les premiers décrets
sortiront dans les prochains jours par
exemple sur le curage en ce moment même
partout en France les préfets passent
amis toutes les normes avec les
agriculteurs pour supprimer ou
simplifier les normes qui doivent l'être
mais je l'ai dit dès le premier jour
nous ne résoudrons pas la crise agricole
en quelques jours oui nous irons plus
loin encore et tout ce que nous pouvons
faire dès maintenant nous le ferons
d'ors et déjà je peux vous dire que nous
avons avancé ces tout derniers jours
avec les agriculteurs et leurs
représentants et ce sur cinq sujets sur
l'élevage nous avons mis en œuvre un
dispositif fiscal qui leur permet de
faire face à l'inflation notamment sur
le prix de leurs bêes et bien nous le
renforcerons pour protéger toujours
davantage nos éleveurs sur égalim c'est
très clair j'ai déjà parlé des amendes
et des contrôles mais je veux dire que
toutes les amendes qui seront infligées
à l'industrie et la grande distribution
seront réutilisé pour soutenir les
agriculteurs
sur la viticulur oui no viticultur
viticulteur souff mais notre filière
viticole et notre fierté elle fait
rayonner la France et donc je vous
annonce que nous allons débloquer des
moyens nouveaux avec un fond d'urgence
avant la fin de la semaine pour soutenir
nos viticulteurs particulièrement en
ocitan sur les contrôles je lance
aujourd'hui un grand plan de contrôle
sur la traçabilité des produits
l'objectif est clair garantir une
concurrence équitable notamment pour que
les normes qu'on applique aux
agriculteurs français soient aussi
respecté pour les marchandises
étrangères au niveau européen nos trois
priorités immédiates sont claires les
jachers les importations ukrainiennes
notamment de volaill et le
Mercosur ces sujets seront portés très
fortement par le gouvernement et par le
président lui-même je le dis notre
détermination est totale et nous ne nous
laisserons pas faire nous prendrons
également mesures pour éviter tout
surtransposition d'où qu'ell viennent je
le sais nous ne sommes pas au bout du
chemin il y aura de nouvelles conquêtes
dans les jours qui viennent je pense
notamment aux jeunes agriculteurs et à
la transmission des exploitations mais
nous agissons vite fort avec
détermination et respect pour nos
agriculteurs monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
réarmer la France c'est continuer à
conquérir de nouveaux droits le
président de la République a fait de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
la grande cause de ces quinquenas elle
sera au cœur des engagements de mon
gouvernement c'est le sens de la réforme
du congé parental annoncé par le
président de la République aujourd'hui
le congé parental ne laisse pas assez de
revenus aux familles bien souvent il est
inégalement réparti dans le couple et
éloigne durablement les femmes de
l'emploi alors comme toutes les
inégalités nous devons le combattre
aussi le congé parental sera transformé
en congé de naissance de 6 mois au total
mieux rémunéré
et que les parents se répartiront entre
conquérir de nouveaux droits c'est
reconnaître et défendre sans relâche le
droit des femmes à disposer de leur
corps nous inscrirons le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
au sein de notre texte fondamental au
sein de la
Constitution conquérir de nouveaux
droits enfin c'est être au côté de nos
concitoyens jusqu'au bout de la vie la
fin de vie est sans doute une des
questions les plus intimes et les plus
délicates qui soit c'est se pencher sur
son histoire c'est repenser aux
souffrances enduré par certains c'est
s'interroger sur soi-même sur ce que
l'on voudrait face à l'irréversible face
à l'irréparable on ne peut légiférer sur
la fin de vie qu'avec la plus grande
prudence la plus grande retenue et le
plus grand respect aujourd'hui nos
compatriotes appellent à revoir notre
droit c'est une demande des familles
c'est une demande des malades c'est un
appel grave auquel nous devons répondre
nous y
répondrons nous renforcerons
considérablement les unités de soins
palliatifs de notre pays avec une unité
par département avant l'été nous
examinerons un projet de loi sur l'aide
active à mourir ce débat animera notre
société je le souhaite je le souhaite
qu'il puisse se tenir dans une volonté
d'équilibre et dans le respect des
convictions de
chacun monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je viens de
tracer les grandes orientations que
suivra mon gouvernement en suivant ce
chemin je propose aux Français d'avoir
pleinement le contrôle de leur vie je
souhaite que la France retrouve
pleinement la maîtrise de son destin
qu'elle soit pleinement souveraine une
souveraineté industrielle technologique
numérique créative d'innovation et
d'emploi une souveraineté énergétique
qui nous protégera des crises protègera
l'environnement et garantira des prix
plus bas aux Français une souveraineté
agricole qui nous permettra de nourrir
notre pays avec de meilleurs produits et
d'assurer l'avenir de notre agriculture
une souveraineté culturelle où notre
création et notre patrimoine sont
soutenus où notre exception culturelle
est protégée où la culture est
accessible à tous mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs je parle de souveraineté
nationale mais c'est aussi par l'Europe
que nous parviendrons à la
consolider depuis 2017 et le discours du
président de la République l'Europe a
changé
elle a surmonté les crises et pris ses
responsabilités c'est grâce à l'Europe
que nous avons pu avoir des vaccins face
à l'épidémie grâce à l'Europe que nous
avons bénéficié d'un plan de relance
massif c'est grâce à l'Europe que nous
soutenons l'Ukraine depuis le premier
jour de la guerre face à l'agression
russe grâce à l'Europe nous avons imposé
des normes aux géant du numérique grâce
à l'Europe nous avons instauré un impôt
minimal sur les sociétés pour lutter
contre l'optimisation fiscale grâce à
l'Europe que nous contrôlons mieux nos
frontières grâce au pacte sur la loi sur
la migration et l'asile un Pact que je
peux résumer en une phrase nous
contrôlons enfin qui peut entrer dans
l'espace Schengen et qui ne le peut pas
grâce à l'Europe aussi que nous
investissons massivement dans les
secteurs stratégiques et pour notre
industrie ceux qui prôent la fin de
l'application des traités sont les
partisans d'un frxit déguisé qui
affaiblirait la France moins d'Europe
c'est moins de puissance pour la France
je ne prendrai qu'un exemple le brexit
ces partisans promettaient des jours
heureux à l'économie britannique au
peuple anglais la semaine dernière à
cause du brexit les derniers auut fau de
Grande-Bretagne ont fermé et on ne
produit plus d'acier au Royaume-Uni nous
en France not notamment grâce aux
investissements de l'Europe l'industrie
revient qui ici était les premiers
soutiens du brexit qui ici a baptisé
dans les ville qu'il dirige des rues rue
du brexit qui ici s'est affiché
ouvertement avec le leader du camp du
brexit le rassemblement national
l'Europe éternel Bou émissaire de ceux
qui faut de pouvoir diriger un pays
veulent toujours détruire un continent
pas un Français ne pense que nous
pouvons nous passer d'Europe pas un
français non plus ne pense que l'Europe
a su pleinement trouver la place juste
dans sa vie ils ont raison tout n'est
pas parfait et il reste des chantiers à
mener mais les faits sont là avec
l'Europe notre puissance est
démultipliée et ces dernières années
nous avons commencé à la changer et je
le dis solennellement à l'heure où il
est minuit dans le siècle face aux
impérialismes les masques devront tomber
on peut vouloir changer l'Europe pour
l'intérêt du pays et nous le faisons
mais on ne peut pas vouloir sortir de
l'Europe sauf avoir d'autres intérêts
sauf à vouloir changer de pays alors
autour du président de la République
avec tout mon gouvernement nous
défendrons la souveraineté française et
européenne nous nous battrons pour notre
identité française et européenne
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs voilà les grands
principes qui guideront mon action celle
de mon gouvernement pour la France et
pour les français pour notre France qui
n'a jamais perdu son ambition de
grandeur pour ces Français qui n'ont
jamais manqué leur devoir ces axes que
je vous ai présentés ils sont une
réponse aux enjeux de la nation
probablement pas la seule mais le reflet
de l'ambition que nous portons avec le
président de la République ils
correspondent aussi au rêves qu'une
génération avait appris à ne plus porter
trouver un emploi stable acheter un
logement fonder une famille faire des
des sacrifices mais acceptables s'ils
servent à l'ascension de leurs enfants
aimer les paysages une culture commune
une société libre et tenue dans une
époque si difficile il n'y a pas de
réponse simple mais il y a des espoirs
tranquille à raviver j'assumerai
toujours de débattre avec vous je
respecterai toujours vos opinions vos
propositions je ne rejetterai jamais la
critique tant qu'elle est constructive
ces mots je les adresse à vous et je les
adresse aux Français je sais leurs
attentes je sais qu'ils ne me
pardonneront rien je sais trouvver ici
dans vos rangs tout ce dont le pays a
besoin les temps sont troublés les
doutes sont nombreux mais l'espoir est
là je crois aux forces de la France
parce que ce qui nous réunit est
toujours plus fort que ce qui nous
divise parce que la France notre pays
notre nation notre Terre demureront
notre fierté parce que oui être français
en 2024 oui c'est une fierté notre
société est plus ouverte plus audacieuse
plus pionnière que l'image que nous nous
renvoyons parfois à nous-même être
français en 2024 c'est vivre dans un
pays où l'histoire s'écrit être français
en 2024 s VI dans un pays qui n'a pas
renoncé au progrès social à protéger les
droits de tous et surtout de toutes et
en conquérir de nouveau être français
c'est vivre dans un pays dont l'honneur
est de se battre pour la stabilité du
monde pour la justice et pour la paix
être français en 2024 c'est dans un pays
qui il y a 10 ans seulement se déchirait
autour du mariage pour tous pouvoir être
Premier ministre en assumant son
homosexualité de tout cela je vois la
preuve que notre pays bouge
la preuve que les mentalités
évoluent la preuve que nous n'avons
aucune raison de céder à la fatalité
alors je n'ai qu'une chose à dire à nos
concitoyens quel que soit leur couleur
de peau leur origine leur adresse ou
leur croyan la France est votre pays et
en France tout est possible monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs oui nous sommes fiers d'être
français et avec vous je veux faire
briller cette fierté française je viens
de vous présenter le cap de mon
gouvernement le cap pris sous l'autorité
du Président de la République pour
reprendre pleinement notre destin en
main et restaurer notre souveraineté et
aujourd'hui nous sommes prêts prêts à
avir la vérité en face prêt à écouter et
prêt à entendre la voix de tous les
Français prêt à agir prêt à œuvrer sans
relâche fidèle à notre devise
républicaine prêt à garantir la liberté
prêt à œuvrer pour plus d'égalité prêt à
toujours choisir la fraternité parce que
mesdames monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs nous ne
sommes pas n'importe quel pays nous ne
serons jamais une puissance moyenne qui
se résignerait au déclin avec fatalité
nous ne sommes pas condamnés à subir
mais déterminés à agir déterminés à
prendre notre destin en main déterminer
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs parce que nous
sommes la France et que rien ne résiste
au peuple français je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
ministre
acte et donnée de la déclaration du
gouvernement dont il vient d'être donné
lecture au Sénat je vais suspendre la
séance
elle sera reprise vers 16h30 pour les
explications de vote des groupes puis le
scrutin public solennel sur la
profession de loi instituant des mesures
judiciaires de sûreté applicable aux
condamnés terroristes et renforçant la
lutte antiterroriste la séance est
suspendue pour environ 10
minutes